hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live nach dem Wumms im Sommer versprach
Bundeskanzler Scholz den doppelwumms im
Herrn im Herbst ein 200 Milliarden Euro
Paket dann Hilfspaket für uns
Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber auch für die
Wirtschaft um uns in der Krise zu
unterstützen Anfang Oktober gab es noch
keine Einigung zwischen Bund und Ländern
wie diese Entlastung genau verteilt
werden sollen und das versuchen sie
heute wieder die Ministerpräsidenten und
Präsidentinnen beraten mit Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz und sitzen seit heute Mittag
zusammen erst haben sich die Länder MPS
getroffen und dann ging es in die
Beratung am Nachmittag mit dem
Bundeskanzler es geht um viel es geht um
die gaspreisbremse um Wohngeld aber auch
um die Finanzierung der Unterbringung
von geflüchteten oder das 49 euro-ticket
also um viel Geld und vor allem eben
auch um Entlastungen die uns allen
helfen könnten helfen sollen und das ist
heute unser Thema wir streamen die
Pressekonferenz die Ergebnisse live für
euch und können auch jetzt gerade schon
mal reinschauen ob sich was tut aber es
ist noch ein leeres Pult zu sehen wir
behalten das für euch im Auge um dann
genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt
hoffentlich natürlich live zu gehen wenn
wir dann auch was erfahren im Anschluss
daran ist Zeit für eure Fragen die ihr
entweder jetzt schon in den Stream
stellen könnt direkt oder per Mail
schicken können fragen Kommentare ich
habe da immer wieder ein Auge drauf und
wir nehmen uns extra viel Zeit im
Anschluss um sie zu beantworten wir
haben jetzt schon wieder bei uns wie so
häufig Nicole Dieckmann unsere
Korrespondentin im Hauptstadtstudio denn
sie verfolgt mit uns mit mir gemeinsam
gleich die Pressekonferenz und vor allem
können wir eben auch ihr und ihrer
Expertise Vertrauen und Fragen stellen
Nicole sag uns doch kann man jetzt heute
wirklich nach dem gepatzten Versuch im
Oktober Anfang Oktober kann man heute
dann mit einer wirklichen Einigung in
allen Punkten rechnen
in allen Punkten da wäre ich jetzt mal
vorsichtig aber wir müssen in den
meisten und vor allem in den wichtigen
Punkten mit Einigung rechnen denn das
können sich die Bundesregierung und auch
die Ministerpräsidentin und
Ministerpräsidenten gar nicht leisten in
solchen Zeiten noch mal ohne Ergebnisse
wie ja schon Anfang Oktober vor die
Presse zu treten vor die Öffentlichkeit
zu treten da musste man blank ziehen du
hast es eben schon gesagt
nach der letzten MPK und das geht in
normalen Zeiten eigentlich schon nicht
und gerade in diesen so unsicheren
Zeiten geht das überhaupt nicht und ein
zweites Mal geht das allemal nicht
wir haben einen kurzen Beitrag auch
vorbereitet indem wir jetzt noch mal
zusammen reinschauen können bevor wir
gleich weiter sprechen Klaus Brodbeck
hat für uns schon mal die Ereignisse von
heute zusammengefasst
draußen demonstrieren sie für eine
Nachfolge des neuen euro-tickets und
günstigen Nahverkehr so preiswert wird
wird es nicht werden noch immerhin eine
Einigung hier zeichnet sich ab drinnen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder beim
Bundeskanzler alle einigermaßen unter
Druck sich heute zu einigen gestritten
werden dürfte trotzdem etwa um die
gleichteilige Aufteilung der Kosten für
die gaspreisbremse in Härtefällen wie
Krankenhäusern
bei der Finanzierung bei der
Administration der Härtefallregelung
sieht der Bund Beteiligung und der
Länder vor die in den Vorbereitungen
nicht
besprochen worden sind also diese
fifty-fifty-regelung die stößt bei uns
auf keine Zustimmung wir werden über
diese und über andere Fragen schlichtweg
mit der Bundesregierung noch zu reden
haben und das macht man vielleicht
besser erst einmal intern bevor es dann
öffentlich wird auch die gaspreisbremse
für alle Haushalte und kleinere und
mittlere Unternehmen wollen die Länder
früher wirken lassen als der Bund
es ist gut wenn im Dezember die
Abschlagszahlung übernommen werden aber
eine gaspreisbremse erst zum März das
ist zu spät und deswegen hoffe ich sehr
dass wir heute auch ein klares
commitment dazu aussprechen können dass
das früher kommt auch beim Wohngeld und
bei den Kosten für geflüchtete müssen
noch Kompromisse gefunden werden zwei
Stunden schon beraten Bund und Länder es
könnte noch dauern
teilweise müssen Kompromisse gefunden
werden wir haben es gerade gehört aber
gibt es dann auch schon Bereiche wo man
sich einig ist ist schon was
durchgesickertes gesichert Nicole genau
das 49 Euro Ticket der Nachfolger für
das ja so erfolgreiche 9 euro-ticket
darauf hat man sich geeinigt da konnte
der zuständige Bundesminister Volker
Wissing von der FDP vor wenigen Minuten
vor die Presse treten und ein Erfolg
verkünden und auch einen persönlichen
Erfolg ein bisschen da hat er sich
durchgesetzt auch gegen die eigene
Parteilinie vor allem gegen den eigenen
Parteichef Christian Lindner der ja in
zweiter bzw der ja auch gleichzeitig
Finanzminister ist und sowieso die Hand
auf das Geld hält klaramt da hatte
Volker Wissing sehr viel gekämpft und
einen Kompromiss gefunden mit den
landesverkehrsministern und nun eben
auch ein Kompromiss zwischen Bund und
Ländern denn da geht es um sehr viel
Geld der Bund hatte anderthalb
Milliarden in Aussicht gestellt unter
der Bedingung dass die Länder gelbe
Summe aufbringen um dann gemeinsam eben
einen Nachfolge Ticket zu erarbeiten und
anbieten zu können nun liegt die Summe
bei 49 Euro für dieses Ticket ich bin
gespannt auf die Details dazu nachher in
der Pressekonferenz den Hendrik wüst
CDU-Mann und NRW Ministerpräsident hatte
heute Vormittag in einer Pressekonferenz
gesagt ja 49 Euro okay der Bund ist den
Ländern ja auch noch mal
entgegengekommen bei den sogenannten
Regionalisierungsmitteln und liegt noch
eine Schippe oben drauf für den Erhalt
des ÖPNV der ja auch unter den
steigenden Energiekosten
leidet aber ob es eben in Anbetracht
dieser Einrichtung die die Preise nehmen
seit Monaten nämlich immer nur nach oben
dann bei den 49 Euro langfristig bleiben
könne das war geehrt zu bezweifeln da
hören wir vielleicht gleich mehr bei der
Pressekonferenz von Olaf Scholz und dem
Ministerpräsidenten
und was wären jetzt Themen wo du sagst
da war es wahrscheinlich schwieriger auf
einem gemeinsamen Nenner zu kommen wir
haben das ja gerade schon gehört im
Beitrag dass plötzlich muss man sagen
heute die Rede davon war dass die Hälfte
des sogenannten härtefallfonds von den
Ländern getragen werden soll
da waren ja sowohl Stefan weil SPD
Ministerpräsident von Niedersachsen als
auch Hendrik wüst eben schon von mir
erwähnt CDU-Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen sich einig darin
dass man damit nicht einverstanden ist
da geht es zum einen wieder ums Geld es
geht ja immer ums Geld vor allem im
Moment zwischen Bund und Ländern wer
zahlt wie viel da geht es zum anderen
aber auch um eine Stilfrage seit Tagen
sitzt eine Arbeitsgruppe zusammen aus
vier Bundesländern und bereitet sich bzw
hat sich vorbereitet auf den heutigen
Tag damit so etwas wie beim letzten mal
eben nicht noch mal passiert so etwas
wie das was man eine Blamage nennen kann
natürlich ergebnislos vor die
Öffentlichkeit treten zu müssen man hat
sich da drauf vorbereitet man war
miteinander im Gespräch und ich schiele
einmal rüber es geht noch nicht los da
war mal miteinander im Gespräch und dann
platzt das muss man so sagen plötzlich
eine Summe und ein Vorhaben in die
eigentlich sehr kompromissbereite
Stimmung das vorher ganz offensichtlich
nicht kommuniziert worden ist da geht es
eben einmal um viel Geld aber auch darum
dass man das natürlich vorher hätte
schon mal ansprechen müssen und die
Ministerpräsidenten damit nicht
überraschend dass die verschnupft sind
ist ja nachvollziehbar jetzt
wahrscheinlich heute auf jeden Fall
unter Druck zu liefern wo es beim
letzten mal eben gepatzt ist es gab eine
oder es gibt eine Beschlussvorlage da
stehen auch schon einige Sachen drin die
geplant sind ein großes Thema was für
viele Menschen ja eine Rolle spielt ist
die gaspreisbremse und natürlich die
gestiegenen Energiekosten wir haben eine
Grafik vorbereitet die wir aber schieben
denn es geht jetzt los und wir schalten
rüber und schauen in die Pressekonferenz
und dann nach geht es weiter mit euren
Fragen und deswegen schalten wir jetzt
rüber zur Pressekonferenz
und das geht los und wir Bescheid der
Regierungschefin und Regierungschefs der
Länder mit dem Bundeskanzler zu doch
ganz früher ordentlicher Zeit ich darf
hier begrüßen natürlich den
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz den
Vorsitzenden der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident Stefan
weil und den nordrhein-westfälischen
Ministerpräsidenten Hendrik wüstes
beginnt wie üblich der Bundeskanzler
meine Damen und Herren wir sind schnell
fertig geworden wie Sie sehen schneller
als angesichts des großen themenumfangs
und der großen Herausforderung die wir
zu bewältigen haben hätte erwartet
werden können das ist aus meiner Sicht
und ich glaube auch aus unserer
gemeinsam Sicht ein sehr sehr gutes
Zeichen hat auch etwas damit zu tun dass
wir die heutige Minister Zusammenkunft
der Regierungschefin Regierungschefs der
Länder mit mir sehr sehr sorgfältig
vorbereitet haben es hat sehr sehr viele
Gespräche sehr viel Arbeit gegeben im
Vorfeld auch am Sonntag haben wir drei
und ein paar andere noch miteinander
konferiert damit das heute gut laufen
kann und so ist es auch gekommen das
sind bedanke ich mich auch
stellvertretend für alle anderen bei
Herrn weil und Herrn wüst dass das
möglich geworden ist und dass wir in
einer Zeit in der die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger genau hingucken was wir machen
und ob wir uns unterhaken gezeigt haben
wir haken uns unter wir lösen die
Probleme unseres Landes gemeinsam
dass wir das tun müssen hat sehr viel
mit dem russischen Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine zu tun dieser Krieg findet
jeden Tag weiter statt der kostet jeden
Tag Menschenleben jeden Tag wenn Städte
Dörfer Straßeninfrastruktur in der
Ukraine zerstört und wenn wir über die
Folgen dieses Krieges hier reden dann
dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass die
Ursache für alle diese Folgen und für
die großen Herausforderungen die wir zu
bewältigen haben Putins Krieg ist das
führt auch dazu dass wir gemeinsam alles
dafür unternehmen müssen das Russland
seinen Angriffskrieg beendet und seine
Truppen zurückzieht damit wieder Frieden
herrschen kann
wir sehen dass der Krieg Konsequenzen
hat zum Beispiel
dadurch dass viele Zuflucht suchen in
unserem Land es sind über eine Million
Bürgern und Bürger der Ukraine in
unserem Land registriert und haben hier
zeitweilig oder auch dauerhaft für die
nächste Zeit Schutz gefunden es ist
beeindruckend mit welcher großen
Unterstützung aus allen Kreisen der
Bevölkerung es uns gemeinsam gelungen
ist das zu organisieren und das nach so
langer Zeit diese Solidarität und
Unterstützung in Deutschland immer noch
anhält gleichzeitig ist das natürlich
mit großen Aufgaben verbunden die die
Kommunen die Städte und Gemeinden und
Dörfer in Deutschland haben die die
Länder haben und die der Bund zu
bewältigen hat deshalb ist es richtig
dass wir über die Frage wie finanzieren
wir die Aufgaben auch miteinander eine
Verständigung gesucht haben
herausgekommen ist dass wir gesagt haben
zusätzlich zu den Mitteln die wir im
Hinblick auf die Ukraine
den Ländern aus Bundesmitteln zur
Verfügung gestellt haben zusätzlich zu
der Entlastung die dadurch zustande
kommt dass die ukrainischen Flüchtlingen
gleich in dem System der Grundsicherung
abgesichert werden und deshalb viel
weniger als das anderen falls der Fall
wäre die Länder und kommunalhaushalte
belasten ist es so dass wir auch noch
weitere 1,5 Milliarden für dieses Jahr
mobilisieren werden um ukrainische und
andere Flüchtlinge vor Ort zu
unterstützen und die Aufgaben leistbar
zu machen für Gemeinden Städte und für
die Länder
wir haben uns darüber hinaus verständigt
dass noch mal für das nächste Jahr zu
machen mit weiteren 1,5 Milliarden Euro
und dass wir strukturell für die
Flüchtlinge die nicht aus der Ukraine
stammen sondern aus anderen Orten der
Welt hier Zuflucht suchen
1,25 Milliarden Euro bereitstellen das
ist eine gute
Verständigung die uns in die Lage
versetzt die Aufgaben zu bewältigen vor
denen wir alle in dieser Hinsicht stehen
darüber hinaus geht es natürlich um
Preise die die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
belasten Preise die die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger jetzt bezahlen müssen und die
viele vor große Herausforderungen
stellen weil ihr eigenes Einkommen das
Budget der Firma das nicht möglich macht
manche Strompreise manche Gaspreise die
neu aufgerufen werden für diejenigen die
keine laufenden Verträge haben sind auch
Vielfaches gestiegen über das was man
vor der bundeskrieges hierzulande
gekannt hat und deshalb war es für uns
alle wichtig dass wir Wege finden wie
wir Bürgern und Bürger Familien
ältere und junge wie wir soziale
Einrichtungen wie wir Krankenhäuser wie
wir Handwerksbetriebe kleine und große
Unternehmen die großen Industriebetriebe
so entlasten können dass wir gemeinsam
durch diese Zeit kommen
dazu sind die wichtigsten Parameter
jetzt festgelegt es wird eine
gaspreisbremse geben die dazu beiträgt
dass die Haushalte nicht mehr als 40
Cent pro Kilowattstunde zahlen müssen
für den Grundbedarf der bei ihnen
anfällt und das ist eine große
Erleichterung das ist mehr als was
früher gezahlt wurde aber das ist
weniger viel weniger als das was manche
jetzt als Gasvertrag angeboten bekommen
haben mit einer 4-5-fachen Rechnung und
all den Steigungen die damit verbunden
sind zu diesen
Unterstützung im Rahmen der
gaspreisbremse gehören auch Entlastung
für Unternehmen die kleinen die
mittleren und die großen jeweils
abgestuft auch im Rahmen des Beihilfe
Regimes der Europäischen Union auch das
werden wir finanzieren
das gilt übrigens auch für gastfrei
nicht nur für Gaspreis sondern auch für
die Fernwärmepreise gleichzeitig
geregelt dass die Mieterinnen und Mieter
entlastet werden sollen und wir es
deshalb Ihnen möglich machen dass sie
diese Entlastung möglichst bald bekommen
und dass das auch entsprechend umgesetzt
werden kann damit es schnell losgeht mit
dem gaspreisentlastung wird es im
Dezember eine eine große Entlastung
geben die dazu führt dass die
gastversorger die Rechnung die sie im
Dezember Stellen nicht stellen müssen
und dass sie die Mittel aus dem
Bundeshaushalt überwiesen bekommen das
Bundeskabinett hat heute die notwendigen
Entscheidung getroffen damit das auch
schon so im Dezember klappen kann und
wir werden darüber hinaus zum Mitte
November zum 18 November entlang der
ihnen auch bekannt gewordenen Eckpunkte
all die anderen Regelungen zur
gaspreisbremse zur fernwärmepreisbremse
auf den Weg bringen und zu dem dritten
entlastungsprogramm das ist die
strompreisbremse auch die soll die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger entlasten wir
haben auch hier eine Deckelung
vorgenommen ich muss mich übrigens
korrigieren bei den Gaspreisen Landes 12
Cent bei den Strompreisen sind es die 40
Cent die ich eben genannt habe die
Gaspreise sind geringer gewesen pro
Kilowattstunde und werden auf 12 Cent
gedeckelt und bei der Strompreisen ist
es so dass wir
da die Preise dort vor der dem Beginn
des russischen Angriffskrieges um die 30
Cent lagen mal drüber manchmal ein
bisschen drunter dass wir das jedenfalls
Deckeln auf 40 Cent für die
verbraucherverbraucher auch das ist
etwas was jetzt umgesetzt wird
einschließlich verschiedene andere
Regelungen die dazugehören zum Beispiel
dass wir ein Teil der Finanzierung
vornehmen über eine Abschöpfung von
zufallsgewinn die bei bestimmten
Stromerzeugern anfallen Windkraftanlagen
Solaranlagen
Braunkohlekraftwerke Atomkraftwerke und
das dazu nutzen die Strompreise für alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu entlasten
ebenfalls ein ganz ganz wichtiger
Schritt also diese drei
entlastungsbremse
Werner und Strom kommen jetzt für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für die
verbrauchen Verbraucher für die
Mieterinnen und Mieter für diejenigen
die Haus haben aber natürlich auch für
die Unternehmen jeweils entsprechend
abgestuft es ist gut dass wir dafür
jetzt den Rahmen gesteckt haben zu dem
Gesamtpaket gehören auch Härtefall
Maßnahmen zum Beispiel für Krankenhäuser
wo allein Strompreis Bremse und
gaspreisbremse nicht reichen und die
haben wir heute auch miteinander
besprochen das ganze Entlastungspaket
über das ich hier geredet habe wird 200
Milliarden Euro umfassen die der
Wirtschafts- und Stabilisierungsfonds
bereitstellt und das versetzt uns jetzt
in die Lage das zu tun worauf wir unsere
ständigt haben die Grundlage ist auch
gelegt mit Zustimmung von Bundestag und
Bundesrat ist der Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds Gesetz wir können
also jetzt zur Tat schreiten und tun es
auch mit dem notwendigen Tempo das jetzt
wichtig ist damit die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger keine Angst vor ihren Rechnung
haben müssen und genau das ist unser
gemeinsames Ziel
herbei
ja vielen Dank
vielleicht erinnern sich manche von
ihnen noch an den 4 Oktober das war das
letzte Mal dass wir hier
zusammengekommen sind damals hatten wir
sehr sehr lange beraten und sind mit
keinem richtig
klaren konkreten Ergebnissen aus unserer
Runde herausgekommen das hat eine eher
kritische Aufnahme gefunden heute haben
wir sehr viel kürzer getagt und kommen
mit doch etlichen richtig im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes schwerwiegenden
Entscheidungen wieder heraus und ich
hoffe sehr dass wir künftig uns ein
Beispiel nehmen am Verlauf des heutigen
Tages und nicht so sehr am 4 Oktober ich
bin sehr froh darüber dass wir in weiten
Bereichen Einigkeit erzielen konnten ich
bin sehr sicher das ist für Bürgerinnen
und Bürger wichtig ist das Gefühl zu
haben dass die unterschiedlichen
staatlichen Ebenen gut zusammenarbeiten
dass sie sich nicht in erster Linie
streiten und auseinandersetzen sondern
zusammenarbeiten und insbesondere auch
diese Augen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in den Blick nehmen in vielen Fällen ist
es ja da haben wir in Niedersachsen
reichlich Erfahrungen machen können in
kurzer Vergangenheit tatsächlich so dass
ein ausgeprägtes Gefühl von Unsicherheit
das Bewusstsein der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger dominiert und dagegen hilft nur
vertrauen dass man schaffen muss das ist
nicht leicht aber es ist möglich wenn
dort der Eindruck entsteht die ziehen am
selben Strang in die selbe Richtung dass
wir soweit heute gekommen sind das lag
wie der Bundeskanzler mit Recht gesagt
hat an einer guten Vorbereitung und das
hat dazu geführt dass Themen die wir
jetzt monatelang im Streit hatten
zwischen Bund und Ländern heute abräumen
konnten das gilt zunächst einmal
insbesondere auch für den ÖPNV
vielleicht ist die zentrale Nachricht
für viele Menschen in Deutschland das 49
euro-ticket wird kommen nach Möglichkeit
zum ersten Januar ansonsten möglichst
schnell im Jahr 2023 die finanziellen
Grundlagen dafür sind heute gelegt
worden und das ist eine wichtige
praktische Verbesserung für das Leben
vieler Menschen wilder hinaus darüber
hinaus sagen dass in manchen Ländern
auch noch ist für bestimmte Gruppen
bestimmte weitere Angebote geben wird
also in Niedersachsen werden wir
beispielsweise für 29 Euro Ticket ein
Angebot machen für junge Leute also
Schülerinnen Schüler auszubilden aber
das ist von Land zu Land verschieden
wichtig ist es gibt das
deutschlandticket zweitens wir sind uns
auch einig geworden es gibt eine
dauerhafte Unterstützung bei der
Unterbringung von Flüchtlingen durch den
Bund ein ganz wichtiges zentrales
Element das hilft uns auch sehr jetzt in
der akuten Krise in der wir uns befinden
wir wissen dass in diesem Jahr wirklich
eine hohe Zahl von Menschen bei uns
Zuflucht gesucht hat wir müssen
befürchten das ist im Winter noch einmal
deutlich mehr werden wir erleben ja
derzeit sehr eindrücklich dass es eine
man muss sagen terroristische Form der
Kriegsführung gegenüber der
Zivilbevölkerung
Russland gegenüber den Menschen in der
Ukraine gibt und insbesondere die
Zerstörung der Energieinfrastruktur der
Wasserversorgung all das hat natürlich
das Ziel gerade in der kalten Jahreszeit
die Menschen dort nicht nur zu
verunsichern sondern auch alles
herbeizuführen dass viele von ihnen
Zuflucht woanders suchen müssen und in
einem gewissen Sinne werden wir so
fürchte ich deswegen noch lange nicht
die das Ende der Zahlen erlebt haben die
zu uns kommen das macht in den Kommunen
enormer Anstrengung bei der
Unterbringung von Flüchtlingen aber umso
wichtiger ist es dass die Kommunen sich
auch unterstützt fühlen in dieser Arbeit
und das was wir an finanziellen
Fortschritten hier heute haben erzielen
können aus Sicht der Länder das ist vor
allen Dingen auch dazu gedacht dass die
Arbeit in den Kommunen unterstützt
werden kann das gilt derzeit nicht alles
aber mindestens die materielle
Ausstattung für die Kommunen muss so
gewährleistet sein dass man sich nicht
im Stich gelassen fühlt
und das betrachte ich als ein weiteres
ganz wichtiges Ergebnis und ich will ein
drittes Thema sagen das waren
Kompromisse die sind uns schwer gefallen
insgesamt bin ich sicher ob der
Bundesfinanzminister glücklich ist die
Länder sind es nicht wir hätten uns
immer und überall auch noch mehr
vorstellen können und hatten dafür gute
Gründe unter dem Strich haben wir aber
gemeint dass die gesamteinigung
vertretbar ist und deswegen insbesondere
auch beispielsweise weitergehende
Forderungen im Bereich des wohngelds
nicht mehr
weiter vertreten allerdings will ich auf
eines aufmerksam machen es ist wirklich
im gemeinsamen Interesse dass wir zu
einem Verfahren kommen dass sehr schnell
ist sehr praktikabel möglichst
unbürokratisch denn die Zahl der
Wohngeldanträge dürfte ganz erheblich
steigen und was wir miteinander
vermeiden müssen ist dass sich dann in
den kommunalen Wohngeld stehenden
stellen große stausbilden die einfach
durch ein kompliziertes Verfahren dafür
sorgen dass viele Anträge lange dauert
brauchen bis sie ankommen das ist ein
Thema das ist heute nicht im Einzelnen
diskutiert worden das ist meine hohe
praktische Bedeutung und daran müssen
wir noch feilen
Stichwort Energiepreise
energiepreisdeckel ich will hervorheben
dass das was Olaf Scholz eben als die
Elemente des energiepreisdeckels
dargestellt hat ein großes Projekt ist
ein extrem schwieriges Projekt ist ein
Thema das ist so in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik noch nicht gegeben hat
und hoffentlich auch nicht wiedergeben
wird und deswegen habe ich größten
Respekt vor der Arbeit die überall
innerhalb der Bundesregierung zu diesem
Thema derzeit geleistet wird die Länder
sind davon ja nicht unmittelbar
betroffen wir sehen uns mehr in der
Rolle von gut es gut meinen der Beratung
die allerdings haben wir auch uns
erlaubt und insbesondere empfehlen wir
der Bundesregierung sehr zu einem
durchgängigen entlastungsfahrt zu kommen
also nach Möglichkeit Sprünge zu
vermeiden zwischen einzelnen Monaten
sowie das geplant gewesen ist wie es
teilweise immer noch jedenfalls stand
der Diskussion ist warum empfehlen
lieber das erstens weil wir glauben dass
es gerade am Jahresanfang wenn viele
alte Vertragsbedingungen ausgelaufen
sind und neue Verträge beginnen ganz
ganz schwer zu vermitteln sein wird dass
man dann tatsächlich nicht nur höhere
Preise sondern auch zu verkraften hat
sondern auch einen Wegfall von
Entlastungen aus dem Dezember und
zweitens möchten wir eindringlich darauf
aufmerksam machen dass vor allen Dingen
für viele kleinere und mittlere
Unternehmen dass ein wichtiges Thema ist
das unter anderem darüber entscheiden
wird ob sie sich selbst dann mit Recht
als Härtefall fühlen müssen oder ob es
möglich ist im Rahmen des Systems dafür
zu sorgen dass diese Unternehmen bei
allen Belastungen trotzdem für sich eine
Zukunft sehen können deswegen aus allen
16 Ländern ganz unabhängig von dem
parteibüchern der sehr gut gemeinte Rat
an die Bundesregierung in dieser
Hinsicht noch einmal in die Prüfung
einzutreten nachzudenken ich habe den
Bundeskanzler so verstanden dass das
gehört worden ist und wir sind sehr
gespannt
wir haben ein zweites Thema das uns
heute längere Zeit befasst hat
nämlich die konkrete Durchführung des
härtefallfonds ist es gut dass die
Bundesregierung einen entsprechenden
Härtefall Härtefallregelung vorsieht es
ist gut dass dieser Betrag auch groß
ausfällt mit zwei Milliarden ich finde
es wirklich wert hervorzuheben zu
hervorzuheben dass damit insbesondere
auch der soziale Sektor abgedeckt wird 8
Milliarden für Krankenhäuser für
Pflegeheime und andere Einrichtungen
deren Refinanzierung auf Pflege setzen
basiert das ist wirklich wichtig was in
dieser Hinsicht und sollte an
Informationen gegeben worden ist und das
wird auch einfach für mehr Sicherheit
bei den Betroffenen sorgen dass wir
gerade jetzt im Winter auch Stichwort
Pandemie ist uns nicht leisten können
dass das Gesundheitswesen verunsichert
ist das liegt auf der Hand und deswegen
kommt diese Nachricht auch zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt
kein besonderes Thema sind dann
natürlich auch Hilfen für kleinere und
mittlere Unternehmen da hatten wir heute
zwischenzeitlich ich sage einmal
Irritation durch die Eckpunkte die uns
bekannt geworden sind die Diskussion mit
der Bundesregierung zu diesem Thema hat
dafür eine Menge Klarheit gesorgt wir
wissen wir werden miteinander darüber
reden wie werden die Härtefälle die
Härtefallregelung die wir alle wollen
tatsächlich sein welchen Beitrag
organisatorisch eventuell auch
finanziell das müssen wir allerdings
erst sehr in Ruhe miteinander sprechen
wird von Ländern an dieser Stelle
hineintreten in jedem Fall das war uns
wichtig geht es dabei im Kern mehr um
eine interessenquote und als Grundlage
dafür auch zu einem möglichst einfachen
Verfahren zu kommen deswegen war das
heute insoweit auch ein Fortschritt wir
haben uns verständigt sehr schnell
nämlich bis zum Ende des Monats auch in
dieser Hinsicht dann zu weiteren
praktischen Vereinbarungen zu kommen
damit tatsächlich am Jahresende oder am
Jahr Anfang dann die Härtefallregelung
in Kraft treten können also ich kann
unter dem Strich wirklich sagen heute
war es ein gutes treffen ich freue mich
die Anstrengungen im Vorfeld haben sich
gelohnt aber ich freue mich nicht nur
für die Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer
unserer Runde ich freue mich vor allen
Dingen für viele Menschen in Deutschland
für viele Unternehmen die genau auf
diese guten Nachrichten gewartet haben
herzlichen Dank
ja seit mehr als acht Monaten herrscht
jetzt Krieg in der Ukraine die Angriffe
Putins richten sich gegen den ganzen
Westen gegen Freiheit gegen Frieden und
unsere Demokratie deshalb ist es wichtig
dass Bund und Länder gemeinsam die
Stärke unserer Demokratie und auch die
Stärke des Föderalismus in einer solchen
Situation beweisen
die konstruktive Zusammenarbeit von Bund
und Ländern ist seit Jahrzehnten ein
Problemlöser für unser Land und da genau
das erwarten die Menschen gerade in
einer solchen Situation und ich finde
auch zu Recht denn Krise braucht
Klarheit die Menschen Unternehmen
Kommunen brauchen verlässliche Zusagen
für die kommenden Monate sie brauchen
einen zuverlässigen Schutz vor den
Belastungen durch die hohen
Energiepreise deswegen war es wichtig
dass die Verhandlung jetzt endlich zu
einem Ergebnis gekommen sind Länder
hätten sich auch früher mehr Klarheit
gewünscht der Kollege weigert auf den 4
Oktober verwiesen Entlastungspaket ist
ja inzwischen vor fast zwei Monaten
vorgestellt wurden man muss allerdings
auch fair konstatieren was wichtige
Vorarbeiten auch zu machen waren
insbesondere durch die entsprechende
Expertenkommission es waren durchaus
schwierige auch intensive Verhandlungen
gerade auch in den letzten Tagen und ich
will ganz herzlich DANKESCHÖN sagen für
die Zusammenarbeit aller Beteiligten ins
andere auch noch mal für die Expertinnen
und Experten die der Bundesregierung
zugearbeitet haben heute gibt es
deutlich mehr Klarheit bei der konkreten
Ausgestaltung der energiepreisbremse bei
der fairen Lastenverteilung für das
Entlastungspaket das Ergebnis ist wie es
auch nicht anders zu erwarten war
natürlich ein Kompromiss aus Sicht der
Länder hätten natürlich auch an mehrere
Punkten noch bessere Lösungen gegeben
das verwundert nicht nicht nur in Sachen
Finanzverteilung sondern auch inhaltlich
aber es gibt jetzt eine
Gesamtverteilung zum Entlastungspaket
und eben auch zur Lastenverteilung und
dadurch gibt es Planbarkeit für die
nächsten Monate das heißt die
gaspreisbremse und das Entlastungspaket
3 werden kommen einig sind sich Bund und
Länder dass das Thema Bürgergeld von
dieser gesamteinigung nicht umfasst ist
das Thema ist im üblichen
Gesetzgebungsverfahren zu beraten im
Bundesrat und gegebenenfalls auch im
vermitt Ausschuss wie wir im Beschluss
auch ausdrücklich festgehalten haben
die Länder haben noch mal einstimmig
dafür plädiert dass die gaspreisbremse
früher kommt nach dem bisherigen Plänen
bleibt eine Lücke mindestens im Januar
ausgerechnet einem der kältesten Monate
im Jahr das halten wir nicht für
sinnvoll es gab mehrere Vorschläge dazu
und bin im Kanzler dankbar dass er
versprochen hat unsere Vorschläge
insbesondere mit Blick auf die
Entscheidung des Bundeskabinetts noch in
diesem Monat auch zumindest zu prüfen
wir sind ja Überzeugung es wäre ein
gutes Signal wenn der Bund die
winterlücke schließen würde es geht um
die klare Botschaft dass der Staat in
diesen schwierigen Zeiten in diesem
schwierigen Winter lückenlos an der
Seite der Menschen und der Wirtschaft
steht Länder haben auch erneut deutlich
gemacht dass es keine
Gerechtigkeitslücke geben darf ein
Viertel der Menschen beispielsweise
meinem Heimatland heizen mit einer
Ölheizung oder mit Holzpellets auch
diese Menschen leiden unter den enorm
gestiegenen Preisen Bundesregierung
möchte das mit einer
Härtefallregelung abfangen ich bin aber
zu einer sehr besser gewesen er hätte
wenigstens vorübergehend auf das
erlaubte Mindestmaß die Mehrwertsteuer
auf Öl und Holzpellets gesenkt dann
hätten wir eine substanzielle Entlastung
nicht nur für die Haushalte sondern auch
für die Unternehmen die wir ja gerade
erst angehalten haben von Gas auf Öl
umzustellen ja das Thema
Härtefallregelung ist dann heute nochmal
akut geworden ja es hat Irritationen
gegeben fakt ist wir sind uns einig das
ist eine Härtefallregelung für kleine
und mittelständische Unternehmen geben
muss die in ganz besonderer Weise von
diesen hohen Energiepreisen betroffen
sehen wenn es jetzt gut dass die
wirtschaftsministerinnen und
Wirtschaftsminister sich darum kümmern
eine entsprechende Regelung zu
erarbeiten
wir haben uns beim Thema ÖPNV
aufeinander zu bewegt bei der ÖPNV
Finanzierung auch jenseits eines einer
Nachfolgeregelung in Sachen Ticket wird
es ganz klar sagen wir haben die
Erhöhung der Regionalisierungsmittel
also der Mittel für den ÖPNV getroffen
die ich für das absolute Minimum halte
das notwendig ist um die
bestandsverkehre weiterfahren zu lassen
es gibt auch Kollegen die das noch
kritischer sehen die
Regionalisierungsmittel sind keine
freiwillige Leistung des Bundes sondern
eine Pflicht aus dem Grundgesetz und das
beste Ticket hilft am Ende nicht wenn
der Bus nicht mehr kommt eine Lösung bei
der flüchtlingskosten ist gelungen und
sie ist wichtig für den Zusammenhalt
unserer Gesellschaft man kann habe ich
nicht mehr dran vorbeischauen das Putin
einen sehr sehr menschenverachtendes
zynisches Spiel spielt mit Menschen in
schlimmer not dass er hohe
Flüchtlingszahlen sehen möchte auch um
unsere Gesellschaften zu destabilisieren
und den müssen wir trotzen indem wir
zusammenhalten diesen Zusammenhalt
organisieren gerade in erster Linie die
Kommunen die da die Arbeit vor Ort
machen die eine tolle Arbeit machen die
auch nicht Murren dass sie die Arbeit
machen aber die natürlich nicht auch
noch sich Sorgen machen wollen um die
Finanzierung deswegen ist es gut dass es
jetzt ein klares Bekenntnis des Bundes
gibt auch strukturell in der
flüchtlingsfinanzierung verlässlich eine
Rolle zu spielen dass ein wichtiger
Punkt dauerhaft verlässliche Zusage des
Bundes wichtig war den Ländern auch die
Unterstützung für die Krankenhäuser und
die sind jetzt Kliniker
Pflegeeinrichtungen glaube das ist jedem
erklärlich man kann vielleicht im
Bürogebäuden auf 19 Grad runterkühlen
aber das kann man in diesen
Einrichtungen natürlich nicht dazu kommt
dass die auch alle nicht von gestern von
vorgestern sind sondern ein bisschen
älter und energetisch nicht im
allerbesten Zustand deswegen ist es da
ganz schön schwierig Energie beim Heizen
einzusparen und deswegen ist die
Unterstützung dort besonders wichtig
Unterstützung von bis zu 8 Milliarden
Euro sind zugesagt glaube das ist aller
ehrenwert hier noch mal unterstrichen zu
werden ist auch wichtig
Sicherheit brauchen auch die kommunalen
Stadtwerke die jetzt sehr sehr unter
Druck gekommen sind deswegen haben wir
uns dafür eingesetzt da Hilfe zu
organisieren es gibt jetzt eine
Kombination von hilf zu sagen der
Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau und der
Förderbanken der Länder im Notfall Hilfe
zu leisten Bund und Länder sind sich
einig dass die Menschen das Betriebe das
Kommunen in einer solch schwierigen Zeit
Unterstützung brauchen wirksam schnell
und nachhaltig dafür sind wir heute
entscheidende Schritte vorangekommen das
ist gut und das wird dazu beitragen dass
unser Land gut durch die nächsten Monate
kommen kann
vielen Dank die erste Frage Moritz
Rödler ARD hier vorne
vielen Dank meine Frage geht an alle
drei an Bundeskanzlerin die zwei
Ministerpräsidenten sie haben ja erwähnt
dass die gaspreisbremse und die
strompreisbremse beide teurer sind am
Ende als die Preise vorher waren haben
sie sorgen dass es am Ende ein großes
böses Erwachen für die Kunden gibt die
dann am Ende denken der Staat hat sich
gekümmert aber die Preise sind doch
gestiegen und man kann das dann nicht
zahlen
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger unterstützen ein
Gesicht sehr enorm Preissteigerung und
wir tun es mit 200 Milliarden Euro die
wir alleine zur
heruntersubventionierung von
Strompreisen Gaspreisen fernwärmepreisen
Verwenden eines klar das wird nicht ganz
auf das Niveau runtergehen dass wir vor
dem russischen Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine hatten aber es wird eine
Steigerung sein die eben nicht so enorm
ist wie das was manche als Rechnung
gekriegt hat obwohl befürchtet das kann
ich ja niemals bezahlen und ich glaube
dass die Bürgern Bürger genau verstehen
dass das auch klug ist dann sich an auf
etwas zu orientieren was uns
längerfristig begleiten wird aber zu
verhindern dass die BürgerInnen Bürger
ihre mit den Rechnungen nicht klarkommen
und ich bin da ganz zuversichtlich das
ist schon eine enorme Summe das kann
jeder gut verstehen 200 Milliarden Euro
neue Schulden zur Subventionierung
dieser Preise sind ein Wort
das ist ja in erster Linie eine Frage an
den Bund aber richtig ist natürlich dass
es eine enorme finanzielle Anstrengung
ist die mit diesem preisdeckel verbunden
ist und deswegen wird man auch nicht
viel Leistung aus dem 200 Milliarden
Paket beliebig jetzt erweitern können
das ist ein Grund dafür ich habe das am
Beispiel der durchgängigen Förderung
gesagt warum wir uns gleichzeitig auch
mit Gedanken drüber gemacht haben wo
könnte man denn vielleicht dann anderer
Stelle auch mit weniger auskommen und
zum Beispiel hinten raus den
Förderzeitraum reduzieren aber ich habe
keinerlei Hinweise darauf dass wir jetzt
sagen könnten das ist ja
unterdimensioniert das was da an Geld
zur Verfügung steht für den preisdeckel
im Gegenteil ich glaube wir können auch
Hoffnung haben dass wir immer stärker
auf wieder in eine Situation kommen wo
Energiepreise zwar nicht so niedrig sein
werden wie vor dem russischen Einmarsch
in der Ukraine aber doch wieder deutlich
bezahlbarer als sie schon gewesen sind
ich glaube es richtig es werden
Belastungen bleiben und da muss man auch
ehrlich mit den Menschen sein umso
wichtiger ist dass es da dabei gerecht
zugeht deswegen haben wir ja so Themen
nicht nur wie die winterlücke sondern
auch die Gerechtigkeitslücke auch
besprochen dass eben nicht der eine der
Entlastung bekommt und der andere nicht
der haben die Menschen in sehr feines
Gespür dafür wenn es schon schwieriger
wird dann muss es dabei gerecht zugehen
und da werden wir auch im weiteren
Verfahren alle gemeinsam darauf achten
Andreas Rinke als zweites
der Bundeskanzler sie haben es jetzt
eben noch mal gehört in der
Pressekonferenz die Bundesländer fordern
unisono dass es keinen rein raus bei der
Entlastung gibt sprich dass die
gaspreisbremse auch schon am ersten
Januar kommt was sagen sie zu dem
Argument hat sie das nicht überzeugt
warum kann man nicht mit Mitteln diesen
januar und den Februar überbrücken und
eine Frage an die Ministerpräsidenten
der Finanzminister hat jetzt
vorgeschlagen die Grundfreibeträge zu
erhöhen und die kalte Progression
abzufedern es kostet 45 Milliarden in
zwei Jahren sie finanzieren das mit ist
das die richtige Prioritätensetzung
zumindest bei den Grünen gibt es
dazwischen danke
wie Sie wissen haben wer vorgesehen dass
die wir haben erst mal vorgesehen die
Vorschläge der gaspreiskommission
umzusetzen und das will ich hier noch
mal sagen da haben sehr kluge Frauen und
Männer zusammengesetzten nicht nur aus
der Wissenschaft sondern auch
Praktikerinnen und Praktiker
Mieterverbände
Gewerkschaftsvertreter Frauen und Männer
die aus der Energiewirtschaft kommen aus
all den Sektor gehören aus der
Wohnungswirtschaft und die haben uns ein
ganz konkretes Modell vorgeschlagen das
werden wir in jedem Fall umsetzen und
natürlich haben wir überlegt was man
noch verbessern kann deshalb wissen Sie
ja dass wir auch vorgesehen haben einen
vorziehen vorzunehmen was die
gaspreisbremse betrifft die
abrechnungstechnisch am ersten dritten
umgesetzt werden soll
das ist etwas was sie bereits kennen ist
eine Technik die dazu führt dass man
dann bei den späteren Abrechnungen das
merkt das ist aber auch das was jetzt
der Vorschlag der Länder
beinhaltet dass man es bei den späteren
Abrechnungen merkt dass diese Monate
auch dabei sind und das können wir
natürlich genau prüfen und gucken uns
das genau an bis wir unsere
abschließende Entscheidung getroffen
haben das Modell das jetzt erstmal
kalkuliert ist und berechne das beruht
auf dem Vorschlag der
gaskommission und ist auch schon so
modifiziert dass wir gesagt haben früher
losgehen soll es auf alle Fälle
die Diskussion über
eine Reduzierung Abschaffung der kalt
Progression die ist erst noch zu führen
ich will nur darauf hinweisen dass es
heute schon Kollegen aus Ländern gibt
die sagen das was wir jetzt zu
bewältigen haben werden das werden wir
schon ohne Kreditaufnahme nicht schaffen
wir müssen sehen dass wir es eben eben
nicht nur mit den Folgen der
energiepreiskrise haben die ja
zusätzlich beispielsweise noch in den
Ländern zu leisten sein werden keiner
von uns glaube ich glaubt dass er ohne
eigene Initiativen vor Ort auch davon
kommen könnte in Niedersachsen stellen
wir jetzt beispielsweise ein
Sofortprogramm in Volumen von etwa einer
Milliarde Euro auf um da gewappnet zu
sein zweitens wir sehen dass die
flüchtlingsentwicklung weiter anhaltend
steigend ist und so gut es ist dass wir
uns heute über höhere Zahlungen haben
verständigen können sie sind ja nicht
insgesamt ausreichend deswegen hatten
wir als Kinder ja auch mehr verlangt und
werden auch entsprechend auch eigene
Beiträge leisten müssen das geht ja gar
nicht anders und so kommen noch eine
Reihe von weiteren Themen dazu so dass
ich eigentlich
nur davor waren kann gewissermaßen
solche Diskussionen gewissermaßen
eindimensional zu führen gerade im
Moment ist es von extremer Bedeutung
dass unser Staat seine Aufgaben gut
erledigen kann und dafür muss er auch
die notwendigen Mittel haben wenn es
dann immer noch die Möglichkeit gibt
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu entlasten dann
würde mich das herzlich freuen
ja wir haben heute ein großes Paket
verabredet miteinander das ist uns allen
nicht leicht gefallen erstens weil da
wirklich Dinge zu machen waren wie die
energiepreisbremse die
außergewöhnlich sind dafür gibt es keine
Blaupausen auch weil die Dimension der
Finanzmittel die gewälzt werden enorm
sind die Belastungen enorm sind glaube
es muss man erstmal festhalten es sollte
ein Ergebnis dass die Menschen Klarheit
gibt und alle weiteren Debatten sollte
man im Weiteren führen heute steht im
Vordergrund jetzt ist die Klarheit da
die die Menschen brauchen um für diesen
Winter planen zu können um gut durch
diese Zeit zu kommen als drittes von
Ernte
vielen Dank meine erste Frage geht an
den Bundeskanzler und auch die zwei
Ministerpräsidenten sie haben jetzt
weitere Unterstützung auf den Weg
gebracht auch für die
flüchtlingsfinanzierung glauben Sie denn
dass die Länder und die Kommunen dafür
gewappnet sind auf diese
Flüchtlingszahlen auch reagieren zu
können insofern dass es auch nicht zu
Zuständen kommt wie
2015/2016 das massenunterkünfte wieder
eingerichtet werden müssen und eine
zweite Frage noch zum Bürgergeld jetzt
wurde die Debatte darum ja vertagt
die Frage geht an den Bundeskanzler
halten Sie dann die Umsetzung zum ersten
Januar dann noch für möglich wenn ein
Vermittlungsausschuss eingesetzt wird
die Ergebnisse von heute kann man doch
wie folgt zusammenfassen
erstens die gaspreisbremse kommt
zweitens die trennwärme Bremse kommt
drittens die strompreisbremse kommt
außerdem kommt viertens das große
Entlastungspaket dass wir auf den Weg
gebracht haben darüber haben wir uns mit
den Ländern auch verständigt und darüber
hinaus haben wir vorgesehen dass es eine
Zusammenarbeit gibt wie auch in den
letzten Jahren zwischen Bund Ländern und
Kommunen all denen die Verantwortung
haben bei der Unterbringung von
Flüchtlingen die in Deutschland
Schutz suchen das ist jetzt schon eine
sehr große Zahl insbesondere Hinblick
auf die Zeit also im Hinblick auf die
Frauen Männer und Kinder aus der Ukraine
aber es kommen auch aus anderen Ländern
welche und deshalb ist es so richtig
dass wir jetzt die finanziellen
Rahmenbedingungen sichergestellt haben
organisatorisch bemühen sich alle das zu
leisten was sie können und ich will noch
mal Zurückgreifen auf das was ich
eingangs gesagt habe es ist schon große
Solidarität in Deutschland spürbar wenn
man sieht wie viele unverändert
angesichts des langen Kriegs in der
Ukraine Privatunterkünfte bereitstellen
und alles tun um diejenigen zu
unterstützen die Unterstützung brauchen
was die Frage betrifft des Bürgergeldes
geht es ja nicht um Finanzen zwischen
Bund und Ländern in dieser Frage das
haben wir auch noch mal ausdrücklich
formuliert und es geht um Fragen wie man
das am besten machen kann da gibt es
jetzt ein Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung der ist jetzt im
Bundestag da wird er vermutlich etwas
verändert rauskommen und dann erreicht
er den Bundesrat alle werden die ganze
Zeit nutzen und miteinander zu sprechen
und es gibt geordnete Verfahren die uns
in die Lage versetzen und schnell
kriegen ich selbst war ja zweimal
Vorsitzender des Vermittlungsausschusses
und finde das jetzt nicht so besonders
ungewöhnlich falls es überhaupt dazu
kommt was keiner jetzt vorher sagen kann
und zum Jahreswechsel wird das in Kraft
treten das ist schon meine Zuversicht
Ihre Frage war ob wir große
Sammelunterkünfte wie 2015 ausschließen
können ich wollte ich könnte jetzt ein
überzeugtes Jahr Ihnen als Antwort geben
kann ich aber nicht im Gegenteil wir
wissen dass zum Beispiel große
Messehallen derzeit vorbereitet werden
das leider auch schon wieder eine Reihe
von Turnhallen beispielsweise benötigt
werden um Menschen aus anderen Ländern
unterzubringen und das ist einfach das
Ergebnis der großen Zahlen die es gibt
sie müssen sehen dass wir in
Niedersachsen ich nehme an das in
anderen Ländern auch so heute ja eine
größere Zahl von zufluchtsuchenden aus
der Ukraine in erster Linie aber auch
aus vielen anderen Ländern in zweiter
Linie zu unterzubringen haben eine weit
größere als im Jahre
2015 im November 2015 und wir haben
jetzt erst noch den Winter ja vor uns
und deswegen ehrlich gesagt die Kommunen
haben allergrößte Mühe überhaupt
einigermaßen menschenwürdige Unterkünfte
bereitzustellen wir können Zurückgreifen
auf Erfahrung die wir
2015/2016 gemacht haben das macht die
Dinge ein wenig leichter wir haben mit
Recht von dem Bundeskanzler gesagt wurde
auch gerade in Bezug auf Menschen aus
der Ukraine auch eine deutlich spürbare
Bereitschaft auch zu privaten
Unterbringungen aber das ändert nichts
daran dass die Kommunen wirklich auch
sich gezwungen sehen an alle
Möglichkeiten zu denken und ein Gutteil
dessen was heute beispielsweise ein
zusätzlichen Geldern vereinbart worden
es wird sicherlich auch dazu beitragen
dass wir immer noch zusätzliche Dinge
anbieten können oder Container Verträge
abschließen können etc nichts davon
macht Freude aber in erster Linie muss
unser Ziel sein dass wir im Winter alle
Menschen gut ein gutes Dach über dem
Kopf anbieten können und einigermaßen
vertretbare Bedingungen und dass das
schwerste das will ich jetzt
abschließend noch einmal hervorheben und
damit auch verbinden ein herzliches
Dankeschön an die Kommunen die Leisten
nämlich wirklich großartige Arbeit
derzeit
ja den Menschen die zu uns kommen
gerecht zu werden ist eine große Aufgabe
wenn man sich anschaut Pferde aus der
Ukraine kommen dann ist das eben was
anderes als wir 2015 Ford folgende
gesehen haben an der Struktur sind viele
Frauen mit kleinen Kindern da geht es
dann auch um Kitaplätze und um Schule
als dann mit dem Dach über dem Kopf eben
nicht getan das muss man so klar
beschreiben wichtig ist dass man dann
nicht auch noch in der Kommune Sorge hat
in Sachen Geld deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir da heute eine Lösung
haben auch strukturell nach vorne hin
ich habe eben den dank unterstrichen
geht da nicht nur darum über Geld zu
sprechen sondern dass man
Verlässlichkeit hat damit klug umgehen
zu können im Rahmen dessen was man
verantwortet vor Ort die Kommunen haben
keinen Einfluss auf die Zahlen die
kommen die Länder auch nicht der Bund
hat auch geschrieben dass er da wo er
mit seiner Verantwortung agieren kann
das auch verantwortlich wiederum tut
aber für uns war heute im Vordergrund
jedenfalls die finanzielle Frage mal
ordentlich zu klären und das ist
Kompromiss wegen gelungen mehr geht
immer die Wünsche kennen keine Grenzen
aber da haben wir heute glaube ich was
geschafft
meine Damen meine Herren ich darf mich
herzlich bedanken für Ihre Präsenz
Aufmerksamkeit und Informationen die MPK
war erfreulich kurz die Pressekonferenz
jetzt auch zum Ende gekommen kommen sie
gut nach Hause schön Mittwoch Nachmittag
und Abend
so das war die Pressekonferenz
erfreulich kurz hieß es und außerdem
auch sehr schnell fertig geworden das
war dem Kanzler ganz wichtig am Anfang
zu betonen nachdem es ja Anfang Oktober
nicht zu einer Einigung kam jetzt schon
Länder und Bund sind sich einig wir
haben teilweise Kompromisse finden
müssen und wir können jetzt darüber
sprechen wir können natürlich auch für
euch einordnen ihr könnt Fragen stellen
ich sage es noch mal direkt in den
Stream oder per Mail denn wir nehmen uns
jetzt ein bisschen Zeit um über
verschiedene Punkte zu sprechen eine
Sache die wird uns am Ende der Sendung
auch noch mal ganz gezielt beschäftigen
die Gerechtigkeit das Thema
Gerechtigkeit Ministerpräsident wüst
sagte es war ihnen besonders wichtig
dass es hier gerecht zugeht dazu also am
Ende der Sendung intensiv noch mal mehr
zu diesem Thema aber schauen wir kurz
drauf was ist also bei rausgekommen der
Bund unterstützt die Länder finanziell
bei der Unterbringung von geflüchteten
das war ein Thema das 49 Euro Ticket das
kommt das war auch ein und wir sehen es
jetzt hier in der Grafik wir schauen in
die Beschlussvorlage was natürlich auch
ein großes Thema war war das Thema
gestiegene Energiepreise und da ist
geplant dass der Bund einmalig im
Dezember eine Abstand Abschlagszahlung
für Gas und Fernwärme zahlt ab Februar
hieß es zwar soll die gaspreisbremse
eventuell gelten aber in der
Beschlussvorlage steht eigentlich noch
drin ab März da könnte es also zu einer
Lücke kommen
Privathaushalte sollen außerdem 12 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde zahlen was ist noch
dabei herausgekommen eine
strompreisbremse die gilt allerdings
schon ab Januar dann kostet der Strom
wir sehen es jetzt auch gerade hier 40
Cent pro Kilowattstunde so über diese
Ergebnisse können wir jetzt noch einmal
sprechen mit unserer Korrespondentin in
Berlin mit Nicole Diekmann Nicole es war
vom Vorfeld besonders klar das was viele
sich wünschen ist Klarheit ist
Planungssicherheit ist das jetzt durch
diese neuen Beschluss da rausgekommen
ja und nein wir müssen um diese
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beurteilen
zu können noch einmal vier Wochen
zurückgehen zum vierten Oktober zu der
desaströse Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
aus der man ja rausgegangen ist ohne
Einigung das sitzt allen noch im Nacken
das hat man gerade sehr deutlich
rausgehört unter anderem dadurch dass
man sich sehr dafür gelobt hat dass man
heute Beschlüsse gefunden hat das sollte
eigentlich eine Selbstverständlichkeit
sein wir wissen seit Anfang Oktober das
ist es nicht unbedingt
und was heute auch passiert ist ja es
hat Beschlüsse gegeben aber was man auch
getan hat ist wirklich strittige Themen
bei denen man heute nicht weiterkam zu
vertagen auch daraus erklärt sich dass
man auch dafür hat man sich ja gelobt
heute so schnell fertig war mit der
Konferenz unter anderem hat man du hast
es eben schon angesprochen
das was Hendrik wüst CDU NRW
Ministerpräsident die winterlücke immer
wieder genannt hat zu schließen das hat
man oben die Länder
fordern bzw ich habe mir das extra
aufgeschrieben so hat es in der
niedersächsische Ministerpräsident weil
formuliert alle 16 Bundesländer geben
der Bundesregierung den gut gemeinten
Rat nicht erst ab März wie es jetzt
immer noch im Papier steht
in die Presse zu springen für die
gesteigenden Energiekosten sondern auch
schon im Januar und im Februar das ist
ja die Lücke von der die Rede ist im
Dezember die Regelung haben wir eben
auch schon gesehen wird die
Abschlagszahlung übernommen und ab März
soll dann ein niedrigerer Preis gelten
bis zu einem Volumen zumindest bei
Privathaushalten von 80 Prozent der
bisherigen
verbrauchsvoluminaten so diese Lücke
besteht weiterhin da will man jetzt
weiter drüber verhandeln das heißt
übersetzt da hat man sich heute nicht
einigen können das ist der eine der eine
wenn man sich nicht einigen konnte dann
das ist ein bisschen untergegangen das
Thema Ölheizungen Holzpellets hatte im
Vorfeld sehr energisch und vielfach
darauf hingewiesen dass viele Menschen
eben auch nicht mit Gas heizen sondern
mit Öl oder mit Holzpellets da gehen die
Preise auch seit Monaten nach oben da
hat man jetzt ein Kompromiss gefunden
das soll unter die Härtefallregelung
fallen Haushalte die aufgrund der dort
gestiegenen Preise ihre Kosten nicht
mehr stemmen können da hat wüst sehr
deutlich gemacht dass er damit nicht
einverstanden ist dass er sich etwas
anderes gewünscht hätte aber heute
mussten ja Kompromisse her
und eine weitere
eine weitere ein weiterer Punkt wo man
sich heute auch nicht
wirklich geeinigt hat das ist ich muss
einmal gucken was war es
da muss ich blank ziehen dass die fahre
ich gleich nach ich gucke hier noch
einmal in meine wild durcheinander
geschriebenen Unterlagen wir gehen
gleich zusammen noch mal durch aber du
hast gerade was angesprochen was viele
Userinnen und User nämlich insbesondere
auch interessiert ich habe das gesehen
während des Streams was das Thema
Ölheizung angesprochen ich will auch nur
ganz kurzen Kommentar dazu Vorlesen denn
es betrifft also wirklich einige zum
Beispiel einer von ihnen Matthias Sellin
schrieb per Mail wir haben seit Jahren
eine Ölheizung wo wir im Dezember 2020
für 40 Cent den Liter Heizöl getankt
haben und letzte Woche für 1,63 € den
Liter er fragt sich wo bleibt die
Unterstützung für die 25 bis 30 Prozent
der Bevölkerung die mit Heizöl heizen
das ist eine ganze Menge er fragt sich
wo bleibt die Gleichbehandlung und auch
monilein bei Youtube das ist ein schöner
Name fragt sich was ist mit Ölheizung
gibt's keine Entlastung das ist ein
Thema was viele von euch umtreibt wir
hoffen da konnten jetzt zumindest das
was heute rauskam euch hier liefern hat
das noch einen Freund den genau danke
ich liefer jetzt auch ich habe es wieder
gefunden in meinen Unterlagen ich
liefere nach es gab ja heute also oder
anders es gab in den vergangenen Tagen
sehr viele Bemühungen dass das heute gut
ausgeht dass man heute mit Beschlüssen
da rauskommt und Handlungsfähigkeit in
sehr unsere unsicheren Zeiten
demonstriert und verunsicherte Menschen
nicht noch weiter verunsichert so das
hat man unter anderem damit vorbereitet
indem man eine Arbeitsgruppe
zusammengesetzt hat aus vier
Bundesländern die in den vergangenen
Tagen sich immer wieder getroffen und
schon mal die Eckpunkte für heute
zusammen austariert hat und Stichwort
Eckpunkte heute Mittag kam dann ein
Eckpunktepapier für die
Ministerpräsidenten also für die Länder
völlig überraschend nämlich mit einem
Punkt in dem es sie ist es würde ein
härterfallfonds geschaffen
an dem sich die Länder mit einer
Milliarde beteiligen sollten das ist
erstens viel Geld und zweitens ist das
stilistisch schwierig wenn man sich am
Nachmittag zusammensetzen will und am
Mittag dann eine Seite der beiden die da
am Tisch zusammen sitzen und sich
einigen sollen völlig überrascht wird
und dieser härtefallfonds da hat man
heute auch keine Einigung gefunden das
sagt man so natürlich nicht auf einer
Pressekonferenz auch da habe ich mir
Zitate aufgeschrieben wir werden in Ruhe
miteinander sprechen also sprich man hat
heute Beschlüsse gefunden man ist ja
auch schon voll der Pressekonferenz
interessanterweise mit einem Beschluss
an die Presse gegangen nämlich mit der
Einigung auf das sogenannte
deutschlandticket auf den Nachfolger des
neuen euro-tickets das macht man
natürlich auch deshalb um gute PR zu
machen um zu signalisieren um ein
Zeichen zu setzen ein Gesamtrahmen
vorgeben zu wollen nämlich der da heißt
das hat heute sehr gut geklappt vor
allem im Vergleich zur letzten MPK was
aber dazu muss man ja dazu sagen auch
wirklich nicht schwierig war also genau
auf diesen Punkt Härtefall Regelung
Härtefall Maßnahmen da müssen wir noch
mal genau drauf schauen denn das scheint
ja jetzt noch nicht ganz so klar zu sein
du sprichst es an vielen Dank für die
Einschätzung Nicole Diekmann nach Berlin
auch heute wieder und gerne bis zum
nächsten Mal sehr gerne bis dahin
und wir können jetzt auch noch mal wie
schon eben von mir angekündigt auf ein
paar Themen auch noch mal ein bisschen
intensiver eingehen was natürlich stimmt
ist kein europäisches Land hat in dieser
Krise so viele Finanzhilfen geplant wie
Deutschland und trotzdem gab es immer
wieder Kritik der Staat verteilt das
Geld mit der Gießkanne und wo das Geld
wirklich ankommt für Menschen mit
geringem Einkommen und was davon übrig
bleibt dazu schauen wir jetzt erstmal
zusammen in einen Beitrag von Moritz
Neuss
viele Wohngeldbezieher sollen in diesem
Jahr zweimal einen staatlichen
Heizkostenzuschuss bekommen insgesamt
bis zu 685 Euro falls Sie alleine leben
ein zweipersonen-haushalt soll bis zu
890 Euro bekommen für jeden weiteren
Mitbewohner soll es in Summe 170 € und
top geben Studierende mit BAföG sowie
Bezieher von Berufsausbildungsbeihilfe
sollen bis zu 575 € erhalten um die
hohen Energiepreise abzufedern hat fast
jeder der in Deutschland arbeitet
pauschal 300 Euro bekommen Rentnerinnen
und Rentner bekommen aus dem
Entlastungspaket 3 genauso viel
Studierende ohne Job etwas weniger
Leistungsbezieher bekamen eine
Einmalzahlung um mit den gestiegenen
Energiepreisen klarzukommen für
Erwachsene die Hartz IV oder
Arbeitslosengeld 2 beziehen 200 Euro wer
Arbeitslosengeld 1 erhält bekam 100 Euro
wie alle anderen profitieren auch jene
die weniger haben vom Ersparnis durch
die eg-umlage denn die kommt nicht mehr
mit der Stromrechnung sondern wird nun
über den Bundeshaushalt gestemmt und wer
Kinder hat dem hilft auch der
Kinderbonus denn das Kindergeld wurde
einmalig um 100 Euro pro Kind
aufgestockt ab erst im Januar steigt das
Kindergeld dann zusätzlich für die
ersten drei Kinder um 18 Euro hinzu
kamen steuerliche Entlastungen so stieg
unter anderem der Grundfreibetrag
bereits ausgelaufen dagegen sind ja drei
monatige Tankrabatt und das ebenfalls im
Juni Juli und August gültige
9-euro-ticket
viele von euch machen euch machen sich
Sorgen wie auch Ulla hartwichsen bei
Facebook schreibt wir müssen aber jetzt
bezahlen und wissen überhaupt nicht wie
ich das alles finanzieren soll und wir
können jetzt genau über diese
Problematik und die Frage wie gerecht
sind diese Hilfen sprechen mit
sozialaktivistin mit Helena Steinhaus
und mit Sozialwissenschaftler Matthias
Wrede von der
Friedrich-Alexander-Universität in
Erlangen Nürnberg hallo schönen guten
Abend
hallo
und die Frage natürlich an sie beide
zunächst mal ihre Bewertung wie gerecht
ist denn hier jetzt die Hilfe verteilt
Frau Steinhaus wenn sie beginnen möchten
gerne die Frage an Sie zuerst
ja meine große Kritik ist das
[Musik]
einfach insgesamt zu wenig Geld bei
Menschen ankommt die wirklich wenig Geld
haben das sind natürlich einerseits
leistungsbezieherinnen aber auch
Menschen die wenig verdienen und da ist
natürlich die Summe von 200 Milliarden
Euro Wahnsinn aber hinter dieser Summe
kann man sich auch nicht verstecken wenn
sie nicht tatsächlich bei den Menschen
ankommt die sie wirklich brauchen und
insofern würde ich sagen es ist sehr
ungerecht dass dass diese Summe durch
die Gießkanne verteilt wird und
natürlich geht viel Geld davon auch an
Unternehmen und nicht nur ein
Privathaushalte lassen Sie uns gerne
gleich über einzelne Kritikpunkte noch
mal sprechen aber auch an sie natürlich
Herr redet zunächst mal die Frage wie
gerechtfinden sie das was da jetzt heute
verkündet und beschlossen wurde
ich finde das Ergebnis insgesamt unter
den gegebenen Umständen eher gerecht ich
glaube seine extrem schwierige Situation
die ja wirklich nicht nur die Haushalte
sondern eben auch die Unternehmen
betrifft und
das Unternehmen dadurch gefährdet sind
das ist ja etwas was ich auch für viele
Menschen die dort eben arbeiten
sehr negativ auswirken könnte insofern
ist es auch wenn das Geld dann die
Unternehmen fließt Geld was letztendlich
auch den Menschen zugute kommt ich
gestehe also ohne weiteres zu dass es
einzelne
Maßnahmen gibt die eher zu einer
ungerechten Verteilung führen aber
insgesamt finde ich
angesichts der komplexen Lage das Paket
weitgehend gerecht
wir werden gleich noch mal auf die
Komplexität auch zu sprechen kommen aber
Frau Steinhaus eben wie sie haben es
angesprochen sie sehen da auch das
Problem Thema Gießkanne wo würden Sie
denn ganz konkret jetzt Mängeln sehen wo
wirklich das Geld nicht bei Menschen
ankommt die ist ganz besonders ganz
dringend benötigen
ja ganz dringend wird zum Beispiel bei
Hartz IV beziehenden Geld benötigt um
die Strom die Stromrechnung zu bezahlen
das muss nämlich aus diesem kleinen
Regelsatz gestemmt werden und ist für
viele Menschen schlicht unmöglich
genau das ist so Punkt eins und dann
natürlich auch ja also die die der
gaspreisdeckel der stellt Haushalte die
wenig Geld haben trotzdem für enorme
Schwierigkeiten weil nach wie vor sind
zwölf Cent immer noch das Doppelte von
dem was die Menschen vor ungefähr einem
Jahr gezahlt haben und und dieses Geld
haben viele Leute einfach nicht parat
sie haben keine Ersparnisse und sie
werden auch so schnell keine bilden
können
also insofern müssen ich wahrscheinlich
die unteren 40 Prozent ungefähr mehr
bekommen als das Geld was durch die
gasumlage gedeckelt wird und auch als
das was durch den Strompreis oder durch
die strompreisbremse gedeckelt wird weil
da muss man auch ganz klar sagen
das sollen nicht über 40 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde gezahlt werden aber die
meisten zahlen gar nicht so viel Geld
für ihren Strom so dass ja so dass diese
strompreisbremse effektiv nur bei sehr
sehr wenig Menschen ankommt
es gibt einen Kommentar hier bei uns im
Stream von Mafia Channel er schreibt
oder sie bei Youtube ich habe irgendwie
das Gefühl dass es bei uns nur darum
geht Schaden zu begrenzen mit
Entlastungspaket hier entlassungspaket
da Bürgergeld da und hier wo sind die
Visionen für die Zukunft würden sie
dieser Kritik zustimmen Frau Steinhaus
fehlt ihnen auch an einer langfristigen
Version
zumindest sind die ganzen Entlastungen
Kleckerbeträge insgesamt also dieser
Wumms von dem immer gesprochen wird der
kommt bei vielen Menschen nicht an
sondern es sind Tropfen auf dem heißen
Stein die versiegen und ich kann mir
vorstellen dass es Lösungen geben könnte
die ja natürlich auch in die Zukunft
greifen würden wie zum Beispiel
dass damit mit mit Geldern verbunden
wäre dass zum Beispiel
Dämmungen vorgenommen werden an Häusern
oder das ja alternative Heizsysteme
geschafft also gefördert werden
die Gas und Energiekommission hat auch
vorgeschlagen dass es ganz praktische
Beratung geben soll bei Menschen vor Ort
theoretische und praktische also das
wirklich Menschen in die Häuser kommen
und die Fenster dämmen und so also ich
glaube sowas das wäre etwas was für die
Zukunft auch Ersparnisse bringen würde
und den Menschen und auch den der dem
zugute kommen würde
kein Wumms und Kleckerbeträge hatte Frau
Steinhaus das jetzt kritisiert das
Hilfspaket Herr Wrede sie haben eben
gerade als sie sich mehr dafür
ausgesprochen haben dass sie schon auch
eine gerechte Verteilung eher sehen auch
die Komplexität dieses Themas
angesprochen wie sehen Sie das denn also
würden sie auch unterschreiben das sind
vielleicht zu viele kleine
Kleckerbeträge oder wie ist Ihre Meinung
dazu das würde ich nicht so sehen also
insgesamt ist es erstmal ein großer
Betrag
und
natürlich setzte sich zum Teil aus
kleinen Beträgen zusammen aber insgesamt
geht es um sehr viel Geld und ich stimme
also dem zu dass die Maßnahmen die den
Energieverbrauch betreffen die die
Kommissionen aufgelistet hat dass das
wichtige Maßnahmen sind mit denen wir
auch wirklich die Zukunft im Umgang mit
Ressourcen verbessern wollen und sollten
also das da würde ich voll zustimmen
aber trotzdem ist es jetzt einfach so
dass sich das Land und die Menschen
aktuell in einer Krisenlage befinden in
der jetzt sehr schnell Maßnahmen greifen
müssen die rechtssicher sind die auch
umsetzbar sind die durch die
Verwaltungen durch die verschiedenen
Stellen die damit dann befasst sind
wirklich
umgesetzt realisiert werden können und
darauf zielten ja auch die Vorschläge
eben der Kommission also etwa durch
diese Dezember
Abschlagszahlung sehr schnell
handlungsfähig zu sein und dann in einem
zweiten Schritt passt zielgenauer aktiv
werden zu können der große der große
Wurf für die Zukunft ist wichtig aber
das hilft alles nichts wenn es jetzt
darum geht in den nächsten Monaten
wirklich nachhaltige und auch große
Entlastung letztendlich herbeizuführen
und
daher finde ich
die Vorschläge gemacht wurden
und die jetzt wohl umgesetzt werden
sollen insgesamt eben sehr ausgewogen
und sie versuchen ja zu verbinden
Entlastungen einerseits auch umsetzbar
schon relativ schnell wirksam auch
schnell sichtbar bei den Menschen mit
Anreizen unverändert Energie zu sparen
und das ist etwas was wir in der
aktuellen Situation und natürlich auch
dauerhaft für die Zukunft brauchen und
wir müssen einfach erkennen die Preise
sind gestiegen sie werden weiterhin
höher bleiben davon können wir ausgehen
als vorher es wird ein weniger
reichhaltiges Energieangebot geben das
heißt wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
dass sich die Verhältnisse nachhaltig
geändert haben und darauf muss und das
hat mir auch die Vortragenden
Ministerpräsidenten der Bundeskanzler
gesagt daraufhin muss man irgendwie
mittelfristig zusteuern
Frau Steinhaus sie haben heute
getwittert und natürlich da etwas sehr
richtiges gesagt arme Menschen können
nicht sparen sie haben keine
Einsparpotenziale und zahlen trotz
Deckel auf jeden Fall mehr
wo ist das Problem dass man natürlich
auch nicht erkennt wo ist das Problem
beim Gaspreis Deckel für Sie dass man
nicht erkennt wer steckt dahinter also
natürlich hinter welchem Gasanschluss
was für eine etwas für eine
Lebenssituation das scheint ja ein
Problem zu sein und was wäre da
vielleicht ihr konstruktiverer
Lösungsvorschlag gewesen
ich könnte mir vorstellen ein Pro
Kopfgeld anstatt einen Geld pro
Gasanschluss sozusagen und das sind so
Überlegungen wie
von 200 Milliarden Euro könnte man 80
Milliarden Euro nehmen und auf die
BundesbürgerInnen verteilen dann hätte
man immer noch 1000 Euro pro Kopf und
hätte einfach einen Betrag mit dem
erstmal ad hoc gearbeitet werden könnte
und ich glaube es könnte auch Varianten
geben wo Menschen freiwillig
zurücktreten davon dieses Geld in
Anspruch zu nehmen
denn ich halte es wirklich für
problematisch dass die Gelder weiterhin
einfach an alle ausgezahlt werden an
Menschen die es noch nicht mal bemerken
werden dass ihr Energieverbrauch in Höhe
von 80 Prozent tatsächlich gedeckelt
wird dass da werden riesige Verbräuche
subventioniert wo es eigentlich wichtig
wäre dass wirklich gespart wird und
diese Menschen reiche Menschen Menschen
mit großen Häusern die die müssen
tatsächlich sparen und die müssen auch
in alternative Energien Invest und
investieren können und vielleicht ja
gäbe es da andere Möglichkeiten als eben
den gaspreisdeckel so wie er jetzt
angestrebt wird
wer natürlich auch betroffen ist ist die
Wirtschaft Unternehmen kleine große
Unternehmen Herr Wrede sehen sie da
jetzt Potenzial das da ist natürlich
auch ein paar mehr vielleicht schaffen
durch diese Krise jetzt anhand dessen
was beschlossen wurde oder sehen Sie da
immer noch große Probleme
ich glaube schon dass es dadurch
gelingen wird mehr Unternehmen durch die
Krise zu bekommen als ohne die Hilfen
und das muss man ja bei den 200
Milliarden auch in Rechnung stellen dass
hier auch einiges Geld eben an die
Unternehmen fließt und
dass da zu auch eben die härtefallfonds
für
Sozialeinrichtungen und so weiter
gehören also das hier relativ
viel Geld
eben auch jenseits einfach per Haushalte
ankommen wird also es geht nicht einfach
darum das Geld auf die auf die Köpfe zu
verteilen ich möchte noch einen Punkt
sagen zu der sozialen Unausgewogenheit
also ich stimme Ihnen sehr zu dass es
eine gute Idee hätte sein können
direkt die
ärmeren Haushalte zu anzusteuern durch
Pauschalzahlungen und das finde ich
durchaus eine sehr überzeugende Konzept
von muss man sich aber sehr früh
verabschiedet hat und ich glaube es
hätte sich politisch überhaupt nicht
durchsetzen lassen weil immer dann noch
die hohen Preise eben zu zahlen gewesen
wären und dieses einfach zu
Nachforderungen geführt hätte die
letztendlich politisch nicht abgewehrt
werden hätten wir werden können und von
daher denke ich dass der gewählte Ansatz
durchaus sinnvoll ist und ich möchte
auch noch darauf verweisen dass er
immerhin diese geldwerten Vorteile zu
versteuern sind das heißt diejenigen die
mehr verdienen oder über eine bestimmten
Grenze die müssen dafür Steuern zahlen
und je mehr sie verdienen desto mehr
Steuern müssen sie zahlen das immerhin
ein Ansatz um mehr ein Gerechtigkeit
vertikale Gerechtigkeit zu schaffen
wollen Sie direkt darauf antworten Frau
Steinhaus
ja mir ist ja natürlich völlig klar dass
auch Geld an die Unternehmen gehen muss
das will ich überhaupt nicht klein reden
und
da können auch immer noch 120 Milliarden
an Unternehmen gehen in dem Vorschlag
den ich jetzt gerade gemacht habe ne und
das ist auch nicht was was ich mir
einfach ausgedacht habe sondern dieser
Vorschlag für die pro Kopf
pauschalauszahlung kommt zum Beispiel
von Claudia kämpfert einer Ökonomen die
sich mit solchen also mit dieser
Thematik einfach stark auseinandersetzt
ja ich
weiß nicht inwiefern das einen
sinnvoller oder ein gerechter Ansatz ist
wenn das immer noch zu Folge hat dass
Menschen tatsächlich vor wirklich
existenziellen Problemen stehen ja also
es müsste zumindest wenigstens eine
Stromsperren ein Stromsperren Stopp
durchgesetzt werden ein
energiesparenstoff in im allgemeinen
weil es wird zu der Situation kommen das
Haushalte ihre Rechnungen nicht zahlen
können dass das auch jetzt schon so wir
machen das momentan viel mit unserem
Verein sanktionsfrei dass wir
Stromkosten von Haushalten übernehmen
zivilgesellschaftlich finanziert weil
die Menschen nicht wissen wie sie das
bezahlen sollen wie Sie Ihre
Stromrechnung bezahlen sollen viele
haben dreifach so hohe Stromrechnung wie
noch letztes Jahr und das ist dafür kein
Geld vorgesehen weder im Hartz IV
Regelsatz noch bei Menschen die relativ
geringe Einkommen haben
Sascha deswegen ich glaube für für rund
40 Prozent der Menschen in Deutschland
ist es nicht gerecht nicht verträglich
nicht sozialen
auch wenn ich anerkenne das ist
natürlich eine sehr komplexe Situation
ist ich möchte mir nicht anmaßen zu
sagen dass es einfach ist eine Lösung
herbeizuführen aber ich möchte sagen
dass die Lösung noch nicht gut ist
ein User von uns Sascha Schulz schreibt
bei Facebook bringt da auch noch eine
Idee einen Kommentar ein gerade in der
jetzigen Zeit trifft es viel mehr die
arbeitende Bevölkerung sollte man gerade
in so einer schwierigen Zeit nicht einen
festen Bonus ähnlich wie Bürgergeld für
Arbeitnehmer umsetzen und sollte man
nicht einfach ein Einkaufszettel auf Gas
und Energie ansetzen um die unteren
Bevölkerungsschichten abzusichern was
sagen sie beide zu so einer Idee
mir immer zuerst möchte darf gerne
antworten
ja soll ich machen
ja also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob
ich den Vorschlag richtig verstanden
habe aber das aktuelle Konzept sieht ja
eben vor dass die arbeitende Bevölkerung
davon eben auch ganz wesentlich
profitieren wird sie ist ja eben nicht
aus ausgegrenzt und ein kompletter
Deckel für die Kosten des
Energieverbrauchs der also wirklich fix
und starr ist unabhängig vom
individuellen Verbrauch den hat ich
denke die Kommission mit guten Gründen
abgelehnt weil dann Anreize finanzielle
Anreize zum Energiesparen komplett
beseitigt werden also insofern finde ich
das gewählte Konzept ein Großteil des
Bedarfes 80 Prozent
herunter zu subventionieren aber die
Zusatz den zusätzlichen Energieverbrauch
über den in der Vergangenheit
gewählten Verbrauch
eben nicht zu subventionieren richtig
denn es wurde ja vorhin schon gesagt wir
haben eine Klimakrise wir müssen um
überhaupt eine gasmangelage zu vermeiden
Gas sparen also müssen die die Anreize
letztendlich für alle für Unternehmen
aber auch vor Haushalte erhalten bleiben
sparsam mit Energie umzugehen
schauen wir noch auf einen weiteren
Punkt in der Beschlussvorlage und zwar
steht da auch etwas drin dass Menschen
unterstützen soll die die Krise am
härtesten trifft und zwar ein Wohngeld
und da steht folgendes drin Bund und
Länder wollen mit einer wohngeldreform
am Januar mehr Menschen entlasten dazu
kommen soll außerdem auch noch ein
Heizkostenzuschuss Frau Steinhaus wie
sehen sie da die ja wie schätzen Sie das
ein wird das eben jenen die das
besonders betrifft etwas bringen
kann ich mir schon vorstellen also die
Zahl es soll ein erneuten Zuschuss geben
von 450 Euro wenn ich das richtig in
Erinnerung habe
wo ich glaube dass es manchen Menschen
helfen kann das hängt aber natürlich
davon ab wie sie wohnen wie sie heizen
wie gut ja die Wohnung gedämmt ist und
so weiter also ich glaube das ist sehr
sehr knapp wird aber für viele schon
eine Entlastung darstellt und natürlich
ist super wenn das Wohngeld ab 2023 mehr
Menschen erreichen kann da sehe ich auf
jeden Fall große Potenziale
wenn wir jetzt zum Ende also noch mal in
die Zukunft schauen nach vorne schauen
Herr Wrede wie sehen Sie wenn Sie jetzt
auf den Winter blicken wir stehen noch
am Anfang eigentlich in noch einem
relativ warmen Herbst es soll also eben
eine eine Lücke entstehen das haben wir
ja heute auch gelernt von einem Monat
mindestens wenn nicht zwei sehen Sie das
als problematisch dass also beim Thema
Gaspreis Bremse dann eventuell eben eine
eine Lücke noch entsteht oder wie
schauen Sie jetzt in die Zukunft auf die
wirklichen Wintermonate die kälteren die
uns noch bevorstehen
also ich verstehe gut dass die
winterlücke schlecht vermittelbar ist
also erst Geld auszuzahlen und dann
diese
Subventionen wieder zurück zu nehmen das
ist nicht gut vermittelbar aber die Idee
der Kommission war ja durch eine
einmalige Abschlagszahlung Übernahme
durch den Staat die Bürger sofort zu
entlasten damit sie für die erste Zeit
entlastet sind so dass man Zeit hat die
komplexen Regeln
umzusetzen und überhaupt erstmal
vorzubereiten die danach greifen sollen
und um das werden wir auf keinen Fall
herumkommen egal wie sehr man jetzt vom
formal beschließt das ganze vorzuziehen
es wird zu sein dass die Regeln eine
ganze Weile brauchen bis sie wirklich
etabliert sind bis sie durch den
Gesetzgebungsprozess sind bis sie
verwaltungsmäßig umgesetzt werden ich
meine Herr weil hat das gesagt die
Wohngeld Stellen stehen wahrscheinlich
vor riesigen Problemen diese
zusätzlichen
Maßnahmen die ich auch für sehr gut
halte
umzusetzen also vieles von dem was da
jetzt beschlossen wurde wird in der
Umsetzung
nicht so glatt gehen sondern wir werden
da davon gehe ich eigentlich sehr fest
aus
selbst dann wenn das ganze erst im März
beginnen soll also die Bremse wir werden
in den nächsten Monaten ähnliche Klagen
haben wie wir sie während der
corona-pandemie hatten über
nicht funktionierende Prozesse
sagt Sozialwissenschaftler Matthias
Wrede vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast waren auch vielen Dank an sie an
sozialaktivistin Helena Steinhaus viel
viele Sorgen bei uns im Stream viel
Skepsis aber sie schauen auf die Saison
dieser Menschen und kämpfen mit
Sicherheit weiter vielen Dank an sie
beide und vielen Dank natürlich auch für
eure Aufmerksamkeit das Kabinett
entscheidet am 18 November über die
Energiepreis bremsen da werden wir mit
Sicherheit auch ganz aktuell bei uns auf
den ZDF heute Kanälen natürlich
informieren und bis dahin vielen Dank
und tschüss